so uh prepara someone who prepares for
disasters emergencies and pretty much
you know pandemics like this we see bad
outcomes in the future and react to it
by preparing for that whatever it might
be
these are the things that we line
ourselves up for so that we don't get
caught with our pants down it's like
getting car insurance you know you're
gonna get into an accident at some point
in time so what do you do you get car
insurance depends on your building
structure for example my parents live in
a 32 story building I think there's
something like 200 units in it right so
what's a building that big and that many
units you're running in too many
transients plus you're running into
people who are visiting them that's too
much of an exposure when you get home
you gotta wash your hands a dozen times
you gotta disinfect the doorknobs and
make sure you know that you didn't
infected so that there's there's too
many variables with buildings that big
it's why my parents left the city and
went to PA if you live in a home you're
in the best case scenario because it's
your home you know who is coming in and
out you know that once you wipe down the
surfaces you find
so I mean listen for a two-week lockdown
the necessities are food and water I
mean you know and your own personal
medical supplies that's all you're gonna
need and you should only buy foods
you're gonna eat like just because spams
on sale doesn't mean you should buy that
crap in my pantry I have a lot of canned
goods
I have Chef Boyardee which I grew up on
it's the only reason why I still eat it
tuna fish
corned beef hash can be a tomato sauce
to make you know like pasta and and red
sauce of stuff dried cereal and meats
that are in the freezer but I vacuum
seal the meats so they last longer
you get probably almost a year of a lot
of it if you vacuum seal it if you have
kids make sure you have an abundant
amount of snacks so that they can eat
three times a day so when you calculate
how much food you should have you should
calculate three meals a day for 15 days
and then you take and me personally you
take one meal out so now your eat you're
extending your 15 days to something like
I don't know wha 22 days isn't like that
so you should ration off your food but
you shouldn't rationale if your water
rationing off water is bad because you
could put yourself in a dehydrated state
everyone should have two gallons of
water per person per day because one of
those gallons are gonna be used to
keeping yourself clean the other gallons
for you to join if you have pets and you
have to prepare for a lockdown for
example with my dog I'm buying bags of
food each week - 50 pounds of bag but he
should be good a month aback so I'm
gonna buy you two more bags and
hopefully this thing passes in in three
if not he's gonna be eating human food
and not humans but like you know how our
stuff we have stored away there's no
such thing as going overboard with
stocking your pantry right so you can I
don't know you can go bananas all you
want but it also helps because if you
want to you know give your neighbor food
or something like that you can't
[Music]
the anxiety of getting sick the anxiety
of staying in your apartment for days on
end you could break down and not me what
you know entertaining this is not 1918
right this is 2020
so we have technology to keep us busy we
have Netflix and the rest of those to
keep us busy if the power goes out
that's a different ball game altogether
the dad I would venture to say buy a
couple board games you know just in case
you get tired of TV and then talking if
you have someone to talk to you live
alone I don't know draw a face on a wall
talk to that but you know if you live
alone then you're gonna have to do a lot
of texting and phone calls
if not then talk to whoever you hear in
the hospital
that helps do some workouts push-ups air
squats if you have a pull-up bar do that
jump rope if you have one you have a
yoga mat do some yoga
um I don't do that crap and I hear works
as far as my home gym bells I don't have
one what I do have is I collect programs
online to do home workouts she could use
a water jugs
cuz they're eight pounds right so you
put them on a rope on a stick you could
curl that you know there's different
little crude things you can do
a lockdown is important in this
situation because of how fast the virus
spreads but if you go against the
quarantine rules or the lockdown rules
you're helping the virus spread all
right so you're taking a person who's
sick introducing into someone healthy
and getting them sick for what if you
don't personal gains or whatever it is
history has taught us that quarantine
works
[Music]
[Music]